not every decision is an economics  despite the fact that the site  statistics that are narrowing time we  did provide a thirty-eight percent  shareholder return over the last year I  don't know how many things will invest  in but I was suspect not many things  company's products investments have been  termed thirty-eight percent over the  last 12 months having said that it is  not an economic decision the lens in  which we are making that decision is  through the lens of our people we have  we employ over 200,000 people in this  company and we want to embrace diversity  filled with Cecily that you can get a  higher return than the thirty-eight  percent you got last year it's a free  country you can sell your shares and  starbucks and vice